Hello, everyone.
It's Wednesday night,
and I just sat down
at my mom's bar, Sneakers.
I can hear the band
doing their soundcheck
and I take a bite of
my Buffalo chicken
and I look across the
bar and see my mom sit
down next to a regular.
She strikes up a
conversation with them
and introduces them to my
neighbors sitting a few seats
down.
I've witnessed
this so many times
at Sneakers that it's
become commonplace to me.
But lately, probably
the last year or so,
I've thought a lot about
the community building
that she's done
so naturally the past 38 years.
And when I say growing up in a
restaurant, I really mean that.
This is my baby picture on
the bar there at Sneakers.
But jumping ahead, I'd say
just about 30 years from there,
I am now our manager of
our professional community
at RStudio.
So in my role, I get to
work with a lot of you all,
either in the room or
watching virtually.
And help connect customers
to be able to share
use cases and best
practices and teach lessons
learned with one another.
In doing so, I've learned
that a lot of what
makes us really good
at our job is not
what's apparent in our resume
or through our prior job
experience or through
the degree that we have.
So when I think about my role
in organizing and building
community at
RStudio, I realize
I've been running my own bar.
There are four,
well, there's so
many things that you
can learn from restaurant
experience itself.
But there are four key takeaways
that I want to share with you
all today that you
can take in building
communities of
your own or growing
communities of your own.
So the first one, find your
Taco Tuesday or be consistent.
At Sneakers and at a
lot of restaurants.
I'm sure we know there are
certain days that are often
associated with certain
foods or certain days that
are associated with
certain events at Sneakers.
this could be having
tacos on Tuesday
or live music on
Wednesday and Saturday.
And people don't come
to every single event,
but when they have
a free night or when
they're looking for
something to do with friends,
they know exactly
where they can go.
And so I try to do this with
our events at RStudio as well.
So every Tuesday
at 12 Eastern time,
I host the RStudio
Enterprise Community meetup.
And this is a meetup
event for people
to just share what they're doing
so they may share a new use
case or a best practice learned
and present for 30 minutes
and take questions
from the community.
And so these happen every
Tuesday at 12 Eastern time.
And it may be people gathering
around an industry group
like using R in health
care or more broadly using
Shiny and production.
Also every Thursday
at 12 Eastern time,
I host our data science hangout,
which I see a few people here
who have been to those as well.
This is a little
bit less formal.
Not that the other
is formal either,
but there's no
presentation at these.
It's just a different
data science leader
from the community who
joins me to answer questions
from the community.
And so all the questions are
audience led from you all
and could be questions like,
how do I talk to executives?
Or how are you thinking
about hiring right now?
Should I have a centralized
or decentralized data
science team?
And these are every
Thursday at 12 Eastern time.
I've included the link to
the calendar for these.
If you ever want to add the
individual events or just
the whole series of
events to your calendar.
This one is best
formatted for your phone,
but if you're on your desktop,
add an extra dash and type
calendar and it will
look a lot nicer too.
But if you're also an organizer,
I just wanted to include that
the tool that I use here
is called "AddEvent".
I really like that.
It makes it really
easy to share events
that people can just
put on their calendar
without having to give
me any information.
So find your Taco Tuesday.
Secondly, start
conversations across the bar.
So as I opened up
with that scene,
imagine the regular
sitting alone at the bar.
My mom might walk over
to them and strike up
a conversation with them
and the couple sitting
a few seats down.
It might be about the band
that's playing next week
that she knows that
they both like.
Or it could be about a
special that's on the menu
that somebody else ordered
across the bar, too.
The topic itself doesn't
really matter as much.
It's just that she's
giving permission
for that interaction to
happen and kicking off
the conversation.
She might start the
conversation and then
have to go walk away
and run to the kitchen
and help with something or
make a drink behind the bar.
But that person sitting
alone at the bar
might stay a little bit longer
because they now know somebody,
or they might come
back more regularly
because they feel a part
of the Sneakers community.
I think one of the Sneakers
regulars said it best,
and this is a newspaper
article from a few years ago.
But Deb is someone who I've
known for many years now.
She's filmed in
employee weddings.
She actually made a video for
my high school volleyball team.
But Deb said it's the
kind of place where
you can go in alone, have
some food and a glass of wine,
and pretty soon you are a
part of the conversation.
I want people to feel this way
at RStudio community events
as well.
Minus the food and wine,
except for this week.
But as community organizers,
we have a responsibility
to bring people together
based on shared interests.
And I think it's important here
that these interests aren't
something that we ourselves
have to be experts on.
But we can go a
step further here
to help kick off conversations
with people at events as well.
I think one of my
favorite examples of this
comes from the data
science hangout, which
happens every Thursday
at 12 Eastern time.
But this particular week
featured Kristi Angel, data
science manager from Stitch Fix.
And leading up to that
session, a few people
had reached out to me on
LinkedIn or maybe at meetups
as well, and mentioned
that they're really
having a hard time
finding a new job
and they were hitting
roadblocks with recruiters
and not getting through
to a hiring manager
because they didn't
have a certain degree.
And so I had the
privilege of knowing this
as the organizer of
the group and getting
to talk with all these people.
So I was able to
ask this to Kristi
for them anonymously
just to get her insights
and hear her experience.
And I started to see in the
chat that everybody started
commenting with their own
degrees and their own non data
science degrees and a
roomful of data scientists
or a Zoom room full
of data scientists.
And it was just one
of those moments
that you just remember,
just seeing people
all supporting each
other and cheering
each other on for their
non data science degrees
and supporting people who are
running into this right now.
So start those conversations
across the bar.
Third touch every table.
So, at Sneakers
it's pretty much a guarantee
if you go in for dinner,
my mom will come by your table.
And Thank you for coming in.
If it's her night
to work, of course.
If it's her business partner,
Annie's time, night to work,
she'll be the one to come by.
And it doesn't matter
if you are a regular
or this is your first
time coming into Sneakers,
they'll stop by and say,
thank you for coming in
and ask where you're from,
how you're enjoying your meal,
or maybe reminiscing
with customers
who have become like family.
Actually, I had no
idea this was a term
until preparing for this talk.
But table touching is a
real thing in the restaurant
industry, and there's
a lot of articles
about how
touching every table
can help create
a guest for life.
In the virtual world
I want to be able to stop by and
meet you at your table as well.
The way that I
like to do this is
when people join
a meetup or a data
Science Hangout is to
write down the names
of people who mentioned
they're joining for the very
first time.
Or maybe it's just a name that
I haven't seen join before,
but also write down
a few names of people
who have been coming
back regularly
or names or faces that
I've been seeing on Zoom.
And this is not possible, I
know, with hundreds of people.
But I don't think that's a
reason to not do it at all.
So I may say to my, oops,
I am I say to myself today
I'm going to write down the
names of five regulars and 5
new people, and I'll reach
out to them on LinkedIn
just to say Thank you,
Thank you for joining
or Thank you for the comment
that you put into the chat.
So it might be just a
few people that week,
but hopefully as we go, I get
to reach out to everybody.
So touch every table.
And the last takeaway I
want to leave you with,
which also expands on
the last, last one.
Sometimes when you're going
by and visiting with a table,
you get a chance to learn more
about someone's experience
and how you can make
that a little bit better.
But not only in what
they're telling you,
but in observing the unsaid.
So I think I've given
you enough restaurant
examples right now that I can
put you in the role of owner.
So let's say over here we
have our table of four who
are waiting for
trivia night to start.
They all ordered
a round of drinks.
Three of them are finishing
up and you walk by their table
to check in on them.
You notice, though,
that one of the drinks
is pushed over to the side.
Now you ask them how
their night's going.
They say everything's
great, but you
can tell they probably
didn't enjoy their drink as
much as they would have liked
to, by the way that it's
pushed over to the side.
So you look at that and
take it as an opportunity
to ask them if there's something
else that you could get them
and insist that you want
them to have something
that they'd enjoy.
This doesn't have to just be
about untouched food or drinks.
It could also be about
stopping by a table
and noticing that it's
somebody's birthday
and noticing that before
they actually told you,
they're just noticing
the little things.
This dining experience
looks a little bit
different in a virtual world.
So let me just take
you on a journey here.
So we'll look at my this
little stick figure here
and we can imagine it as
anyone, but we'll call him Bob.
So Bob joins a meetup event for
the first time and listens in.
Maybe Bob was on the list
of one of the five people
that I wrote down
as a new person.
Or maybe he wasn't.
He comes back again and joins
in listen only mode again.
A week later, he
comments in the chat
and then I notice
Bob on mute briefly.
It pops up to the top of my Zoom
but doesn't end up speaking.
So I am not going to
say to Bob on LinkedIn,
hey, you join three
times and you never talk.
What can I do to make you
feel more comfortable?
But I might say something
like, hey, Bob, Thanks
so much for joining today.
I loved your comment about
learning R as a SAS user.
I think that perspective
was incredibly helpful.
If you ever have any
suggestions or things
that we could be doing to
make this event more useful,
please let me know.
And Bob might say,
Thanks for joining,
I had a great time.
I wanted to ask a
question, but I wasn't sure
if it was the right format.
And so I've had the opportunity
now to learn something
more about Bob's experience
by thanking him for coming
and by just noticing that
there was something there
in the unsaid.
And so what Bob
does for me here is
I have that opportunity to say,
did you oh, oh, gosh, this is.
There we go.
Did that you can ask
questions anonymously as well?
And so,
I can let him know,
this is a place for any
question to be asked.
But there's
something more there.
It points out to
me that I didn't
make it clear, maybe in the
beginning of the presentation
that people could ask
questions anonymously.
And if I said that once,
maybe that's not enough.
Because if somebody joined
a few minutes later,
they would have missed that.
So it lets me know
that that's something I
should put in the chat as well.
So a month later, maybe he keeps
coming back and keeps joining
and eventually presents
at the meetup as well.
I think this is one of my
favorite things about community
building.
Is seeing somebody come
for the very first time.
And then starting to
get to know people
and you see them like
being friends on Twitter
or commenting on each
other's LinkedIn posts.
And then eventually that
person being the one presenting
at the event too.
So today I've given
you four key takeaways
that I've learned from
growing up at Sneakers.
But there are so many
more tips out there
from amazing community
builders and community
organizers like you all.
I know there are so many
here in the audience
today at the conference and
watching virtually as well.
So I wanted to take
this opportunity
to share this resource as well.
A few months ago.
I guess it's not that new now.
A few months ago, I helped build
the site, RStudio.com/champion,
and it was designed
to help people
advocate for data science
at their own organizations.
And when they're
facing roadblocks
to have a place to go, but
also included a section
on community building.
And this includes a lot
of knowledge and resources
from amazing community
builders out there and people
that I've met at other events.
There's also a feedback form on
the very bottom of this site,
if you scroll to it, where
you can share your own tips
and tricks.
Or ask to see something else
that's maybe not there yet.
I just want to say Thank
you so much to all of you
for being here today.
And it's amazing to see you
all at the conference, too.
I want to say a big Thank you
to my mom, Rhonda Dempsey, who
I learned so much from and
continue to learn so much from.
Also, a huge congrats to her
and her business partner, Annie,
who are celebrating 38 years
in business at Sneakers
cafe this week.
And also feel like in
case my mom and dad
were watching to say happy
anniversary to them too,
because today is their
actual anniversary.
But just like Sneakers
would not be the same
without their community.
R and RStudio and
soon to be Posit
would definitely not be the
same without all of you.
Thank you so much
again for being here.
If you have any questions,
I'd love to hear them.
I'd also put my LinkedIn
and Twitter up on the screen
as well because I would
love to connect there.
LinkedIn is probably
the preference.
I'll also take questions
on the Discord channel
communities of practice, too.
Thank you, everybody.